hi there in this video I'm going to show
you how to use the translation features
of Microsoft PowerPoint to translate
your presentations into any of the
languages supported by Microsoft
translator I recently received a copy of
a PowerPoint presentation
from a team in Cairo Egypt the
presentation was given in Arabic and
unfortunately I can't read the slides
luckily I can use the translation
features that are already embedded in
Microsoft PowerPoint to translate them
automatically to translate the text I
just select the text I want to translate
click on the review tab near the top of
the window
choose translate and choose translate
selected text
now a research window opens up on the
right side of the screen in the research
window I can choose the language I want
to translate the text to from all of the
languages supported by Microsoft
translator in this case I would like to
translate it from arabic to english
I can press insert to replace the text
or copy to add the translation to my
clipboard so that I can use it somewhere
else here I'll press insert and you can
see the English translation on the slide
if you use the translation feature a lot
you may want to add translate to the
quick access toolbar at the top of your
PowerPoint menu to do this simply click
on the customize quick access toolbar at
the top select more commands
choose review tab from the list of
commands
and select translate from the menu
once I've highlighted translate in the
menu press add and okay and now the
translate feature will appear in the
quick access toolbar now I can quickly
translate the text of the next slide by
highlighting the text clicking on the
translator icon in the toolbar and
pressing insert
you may have noticed earlier when I
clicked on the translate features in the
review tab that I was also given an
option for the mini translator the mini
translator allows you to get instant
translations of words as you hover over
them in the document for instance when I
select the title of the slide here it
shows me the translation of the title in
English to set the target language for
the mini translator select translate
from the review tab as before and select
choose translation language just choose
the language you want and you're ready
to go
the mini translator is also available in
Outlook OneNote and word
I hope this video has been helpful in
explaining the translation features in
PowerPoint for more videos about
microsoft translator check out our
youtube channel at WWE kao ms /
translator youtube thank you very much
you